thor ragnarok is the best thor movie so
far and coming just months before the
Avengers Assemble for infinity war the
movie includes a mid-credits teaser plus
a second post credit scene yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers it's Jan here I just saw
Thor Ragnarok and can confirm the
details of two end credits scenes in the
movie before I get into them a quick
spoiler warning I'll avoid discussing
the movie's biggest plot points in this
video but if you want to avoid any
spoilers you can tap here for my spoiler
free video with the soul Ragnarok cast
at Comic Con I'm also starting my full
Ragnarok giveaway on this video for your
chance to win a cool Marvel Funko pop
all you have to do is be a subscriber to
my channel and leave a comment below
about Thor Ragnarok or Avengers infinity
war the first credits seen in Thor
Ragnarok arrives just after the end of
the animated credits and features Thor
and Loki who've just left as God and are
now on a spaceship headed to earth
though Loki wonders whether it's really
a good idea for him to return there give
him what he did in the Avengers movie
Thor quips that the god of thunder is
really popular on earth and everything
will be fine
but just as Thor says that an enormous
craft comes into view completely
dwarfing Thor and Loki spaceship in
comparison this ominous moment is
teasing the arrival of Thanos in what is
probably one of his sanctuary ships in
the comics sanctuary is the name given
to several thanasis space arks which
he's used as a base for conducting
operations as for the MCU sanctuary is
identified in guardians of the galaxy
astonishes domain in space and it also
briefly appeared in The Avengers in the
Avengers infinity war trailer shown at
d23 and comic-con there's a moment where
Thor appears floating through space and
then lands on the windshield of the
Guardians valano ship which means that
the Ragnarok mid-credits scene is
probably setting up for Thanos to meet
Thor and Loki in space it looks like
Thor is going to get beaten by Thanos
who might even destroy the ship Thor is
on and it might also explain why in the
infinity war trailer Loki appears to be
offering the tesseract aka the space
stone to Thanos in the Thor Ragnarok
there's a strong hint that Loki steals
the tesseract for himself
meaning that Loki will likely have it on
him when they meet Thanos and remember
that in the event
movie Loki had agreed to steal the
tesseract Thanos in return for ruling
over earth Thanos may well be furious at
Loki for his failure so far so Loki may
need to give up the Infinity stone to
save himself the other Ragnarok
post-credits scene is a humorous one
that features a Grand Master stumbling
out for container on sir car as he
staggers out he meets a group of
Sakhalin staring at him in thor ragnarok
the Grand Master is an eccentric
dictator who rules over the planet
sakaar
where he enslaves gladiators to fight in
his contest of Champions
the gladiators eventually rebel against
the Grandmaster and in this post-credit
scene the Grandmaster congratulates as
the Curran's on a successful revolution
and Pat's himself on the back for
helping to make the uprising such a huge
success and declares rebellion to be a
time Jeff Goldblum delivers some of his
great trademark off-the-wall humor in
this scene which also leaves the door
open for him to return in a future MCU
movie so what do you think about the
thor ragnarok
end credits scenes and what do you think
they mean for Avengers infinity war let
me know in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe for all my upcoming
school Ragnarok videos plus your chance
to win a marvel Funko pop winners will
be announced on a future video so hit
the bell to get notified of all my new
videos if you enjoyed this I really
appreciate all your support and you can
check out some more videos you might
like right here thanks for watching and
see you next time you became weary
lovers
you